hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast assembly an analysis of non
model organism transcriptomes using DNA
star software I am Brenda Kelly Kim lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcasts presented
by lab routes comm the meeting social
media site for science professionals and
sponsored by DNA star DNA star is a
global software company headquartered in
Madison Wisconsin that has been meeting
the needs of life scientists for 25
years we grew out of the e.coli
laboratory of dr. Fred blattner
professor of genetics at the University
of Wisconsin in nineteen eighty four
hour early products reflected this
background in association we built a
strong reputation during the Sanger
sequencing years of providing
outstanding desktop software for DNA
protein sequence assembly and analysis
before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answer hose always welcome to
you can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and type in your
comments and questions in the box we'll
try to get to as many as we can and
we'll follow up if we don't have time
today if you want a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
he hear or see this presentation
properly please let us know by clicking
on the support button at the top right
or use the Q&A button we'll make sure we
try to resolve any issues now let's get
right to today's presenter we are proud
to welcome Matthew Kaiser Matthew Kaiser
is senior manager NGS applications for
DNA star where he has helped scientists
address their sequence assembly and
analysis challenges for the past seven
years Matt sole focus at DNA start
supporting customers in next-gen
sequencing applications using DNA stars
broad software tool set map helps
customers with their templated and de
novo assembly projects transcriptomes
excel
metagenomic semblance RNA seek chips
seek and numerous other unique
experiments that has helped hundreds of
scientists optimize their workflows
using dynast DNA stars next-gen software
solutions he has also spoken at numerous
conferences and workshops regarding the
capabilities of DNA stars next-gen
software tools I'll now turn the
presentation over to Matt Thank You
Brenda and thank you for joining me this
afternoon today our topic will be
assembly analysis of non model organism
transcriptomes using some new features
in DNA star software I'm excited to
introduce this new workflow there's some
novel new algorithms and some novel new
analysis methods that we provide
downstream and our software and I'd like
to introduce the company as well I have
a few slides here to give you some
background in DNA star and of course
I'll be around after the presentation to
answer any questions that you may have
so DNA star has software in three main
areas molecular biology and genomics and
structural biology my role at the
company has been mostly to focus in the
genomics area and you'll see that
there's a wide variety of different
types of genomics workflows that that we
can support and we'll describe some of
those in detail really investigate this
new workflow that was developed earlier
this year our company was founded by dr.
Fred blattner and John Schrader out of
the University of Wisconsin we've been
in business for over 30 years our
software is was developed first to help
support efforts with the E coli k12
genome dr. blattner as a pioneer
genomics pioneer and was the first
sequence bacterial genome our software
is in many different countries it's
worldwide it's it's used at academic
institutions government's healthcare
commercial customers we have site
licenses we have institution licenses
and individual licenses for researchers
again very flexible series of options
or how you can gain access to the
software and I'll describe some of that
in detail at the end of the talk our
support is worldwide as well our main
office hours are central time 7 am-6
p.m. what's really great about DNA star
is that you can you can call in and
speak with a representative we can chat
myself I work with with customers on
their data set so we exchange data sets
often and I can i can help you work
through problems or any questions that
you have so it's really the top match
level of support is one of the key
aspects to DNA star we also have
additional global locations and
distributors throughout throughout the
world so so we do software for
researchers and are really our goal is
to provide extremely powerful solutions
I'm in easy-to-use format and make them
accessible either you know through a
desktop computer or more recently we
have some cloud options as well and so
that's something we continue to strive
for even as datasets get much larger and
of course when NGS hit the scene several
years ago there's a great challenge
because the amount of data produced
sometimes exceeded what a typical
desktop computer could handle what we're
gonna be doing today is looking at a
workflow route we really tackled a large
problem that's large de novo assembly of
transcriptomes on desktop computers so
it's really quite a feat to handle these
large datasets on regular computers
because we've you know had research
software for many many years now and
we've got over 50,000 publications or
the most cited bioinformatics software
company that's out there so we all the
way back to the 1980s you can see it's
an increasing trend so we have more and
more usage worldwide and you know in a
larger and larger a user base so to
really some laser Gina we provide all
the software tools that we can to cover
the three areas of molecular biology
genomics and structural biology and we
do our best to provide excellent tools
in all areas and the tools look
different in different ways we have the
biology that include things like
phylogenetic analysis you know multiple
sequence alignment we have sequence
editors so things that can support
features primer design sequence editing
multiple different ways circular maps
and linear maps to visualize the data so
kind of the nuts and bolts of sequence
analysis we have a whole suite of tools
that can that can perform all those
functions we also have structural
biology that is relatively new it's in
our newest format it expands on some of
our protein analysis and does things
like protein modeling and prediction of
structure so really an excellent set of
tools we have new tools that really
expand on these capabilities release
later this year so if you are interested
in structural biology please keep an ind
and I star and check out some of the
tools that we have and of course
genomics that's what we're going to
focus on today genomics covers a wide
range of different topics and really I'm
going to look talk about two different
workflows that kind of combined for
transcriptomic sand and will you'll get
an idea of what our tools can do even
with challenging organisms and that's
really kind of a nice niche for us is we
have flexible enough tools that we can
accommodate folks that aren't working in
the main model organisms if you may not
have a reference genome to align to you
can start from scratch with our software
and build your own reference sequences
and do your analysis and so it's that
are really exciting workflow so so
really any kind of a project de novo
transcriptome the RNA seek to exomes and
genomes and multiple genome of alignment
in comparison and all the different
sequencing platforms and of course
alumina and I in torrent pacbio we're
working to be compatible with on
nanopore technologies we're working hard
there to have some great solutions for
the long reads that are that are sudden
hit the market and our hardware
requirements again if you're going to
try out the software you may have some
questions whether or not your hardware
the of in place is sufficient for these
larger projects like the noble
transcriptome assemblies my
recommendation is to have a you know
could be a laptop or a desktop computer
but what's really
important is to have a extra space for
and this is what it calls a scratch disk
and you really want to have that extra
space to handle the temporary files that
are generated during the assembly and on
my laptop I just plug in a just as a
couple terabytes in size and that can
handle the vast majority of exomes and
transcriptomes and RNA seek projects
that I do and of course if you're doing
a lot of data another drive for storage
if you're generating hundreds of gigs or
terabytes of data you don't want to have
a adequate storage drive but you know
nowadays computers are so fast and they
have multiple cores and lots of RAM you
know even your budget desktop computer
can handle even the most demanding type
of projects another option especially if
you're if you're trying the software out
you may not have any hardware or your
Institute you might have to get updates
more than every five years or so which
which is more common than you'd think we
also have the ability to run the
assemblies up on the Amazon Cloud and so
what this entails is you still set
everything up locally you know you take
your data you set up the assembly set
your parameters but when you really hit
the assemble button what's happening is
the data is getting zipped up encrypted
and uploaded to the Amazon Cloud and
then a virtual computer is spun up and
you use Amazon's hardware than to run
the assembly and then of course you can
just download it locally to do the
analysis the there's some advantages to
the cloud one advantage is that you can
do a whole bunch of assemblies in a very
short amount of time and so you know for
instance if you've got you know ten
exomes and you need them done by
tomorrow that might be difficult to do
you know on a single desktop computer
but I can send those ten jobs up easily
and run them simultaneously using the
cloud resources the other big advantage
is that you can easily share data you
can have colleagues from all the world
login access the data upload data to you
and bring the data back down so it's
it's there's some real conveniences to
the cloud and of course it's here if
your computer blows up one day you still
have your data up on up on Amazon so if
you're interested if cloud there's more
information on
website and sales reps if I can give you
pricing and additional information so
now the focus at DNA star has really
been really in the last two to three
years has been to make our software as
accurate as is possible and there's lots
of different ways to measure accuracy
but in this particular case the accuracy
is measured via snip calling and
detecting known variants in a reference
data set and surprisingly those
reference data sets really haven't been
available until you know just in the
last of three years or so and these are
human data sets that are available at
the NIH the GM and a bottle consortium
where a large portion of this particular
human genome has been sequenced using
multiple different technologies and the
snips are verified so so you can check
the answer essentially take software
like DNA star get a data set for that
for that genome align it and check do
you find all the snip that you're
supposed to in this known answer and
when we do those kind of analyses and we
have a workflow that's a whole different
webinar we won't put on that path now
but we have that workflow built into the
software so as long as you just download
that data set and assemble it I will
calculate for you you know using maybe
your own capture technique in your own
sequencing core you are you getting 99.7
percent accurate and so it's a
validation work full that we built into
our software so you can validate your
own process and so it's nice about this
is the same assembly and sniff caller
and gapping and it is used for all the
different organisms so if you're working
in a non model you know that this is
very very accurate software and it's
going to do a very very good job
assembling that data and some of the
some of the results here this is just
far from our website but you can see
that there's a consistent performance
these are what this is our three human
exomes and it's this na 12 8 7 8 X on
this is the answer essentially we're
checking against and when we look at
exome data from garvan institute Eric
labs Mount Sinai we see that the
sensitivity in those cases is always
over ninety-nine percent it's for some
of the datasets looking on Sinai it's
over nine
nine point nine percent in the assembly
time a couple of hours again on a
desktop computer lots of data so we have
a very fast assembly time very accurate
sensitivity when detecting these mill
and variations so those those same
algorithms then that take sequence data
and align it to a reference we use those
for other workflows now the de novo
transcriptome is actually a brand new
algorithm that can take massive amounts
of data and the Nobel assemble through a
series of steps it will be Noble
assemble that data and then compare it
to a reference database and pull an
annotation so it's kind of a multi-step
workflow and then of course we can
proceed on RNA seek so we're going to
look at two workflows I've related first
we're going to de novo assemble our
transcriptome then we're going to use
our assembled annotated transcripts and
use those as references then to do some
gene expression quantitation with
different different sets so it's it's
kind of a hand in hand workflow but it
is multiple step and we try to automate
as much of that as possible so some of
the challenges with the Nobel
transcriptome assemblies if you if
you've done these at all you know that
with a Lumina data in particular if you
have high seat Illumina you're getting
millions of reads you know oftentimes
it's hundreds of millions of sequence
reads and most of the noble algorithms
that are available are memory limited so
what that means is you usually have to
get access to a big Linux cluster that
can be very expensive and run that for
you know hours if not days to do a de
novo assembly so it can be very costly
than if you are Iran change parameters
becomes a time-consuming and expensive
ordeal and then the output is you know
however many different mr and I mrna
isoforms are present you'll get a
content for each one of those isoforms
so you have potentially tens of
thousands of context that are
unannotated that come out the the
assembler and you have to do something
with those often times you want to
figure out what they are so you want to
annotate them if your organism is is
novel there may be limited annotations
just for anyone
keeler reference organism you may want
to draw annotations from multiple
organisms so it becomes very daunting
working with thousands of context to
apply annotations and then turn around
and you make use of those annotations
there's also sometimes you may need to
edit individual transcripts that are
important to you you may need to piece
them together so this new workflow
provides all the different it automates
the more difficult steps and gives the
user the ability and some flexibility to
work with work with the output so some
of the benchmarks know this is pretty
early benchmarking and I can will be
adding more data here this is for a
particular data set and you can see that
there's a couple things one is the
assembly time versus input reads [ __ ]
can put an arrow on here so it's a
little bit small so number of input
reads so these data sets the smaller
ones have about 50 million reads the
bigger ones can have closer to 500
million half-billion reads there are
some that are even bigger I've seen
datasets with over a billion reads in
them and so with this new algorithm our
assembly time is fairly it's a fairly
linear relationship and so you know
roughly 12 hours per hundred million
reads for this data set some datasets
take a little longer they may be more
complex or have things in them that are
more difficult like ribosomal RNA it
hasn't been removed completely so it
makes the clustering a little bit more
complicated but they're generally you
know a rough rule of thumb is about you
know 12 hours per hundred million the
number of transcripts generated you can
see that the at about a hundred million
as well it starts to diminished so for
many data sets you get most of the
transcripts with a hundred million reads
and what's happening is as there's
enough coverage on most of the express
jeans with a hundred million reads that
pretty much everything that's there de
novo assembles as you dump more data in
you do pick up some more transcripts
sometimes its fragments of transcripts
or rare isoforms or sometimes it's some
other kind of a contamination but for
most folks around a hundred million
reads you generally get nice coverage
of your transcript film and it kind of
you can see that it really does plateau
at about a hundred million read so it's
something to keep in mind as you're
generating data you may not need you
know an excess of data get all coverage
that you actually need or require so the
particular data set that we're to look
at today it's a Nile tilapia just I
randomly selected this off of the short
read archive you can see the study here
is up on the SRA so you can download
this data and this particular data set
has its alumina hi-c 2000 runs six and a
half Giga bases of data and it has three
different samples from different tissue
types so just up you know
run-of-the-mill kind of a RNA seek
transcriptome data set and the organism
does not have a sequence genome that's
well annotated right so there's a
limited amount of annotated transcript
so it's a typical kind of organism
someone might want to do a Genoa
betraying script home assembly with so
the so the software then to start out
it's it's our seek man engine we call
this a wizard and the wizard is a
starting point then from for launching
the NGS assemblies and I can you can see
here that we have different options
assemble on a local computer rerun a
local assembly or assemble on the DNA
start cloud and at any one of these
points on a Semel on a local computer it
just proceeds to the next step in the
wizard there's a next button down here
that that allows me to advance by
someone the cloud it will ask for
credentials that check Oh does this
person have a cloud account yes then you
proceed the set of the assembly the next
option is to choose the assembly
workflow and the assembly workflow then
you can see there's DNA seeking
genotyping and transcriptomics and some
other workflows and as you make
decisions here it really starts to go
down kind of a tree of different
parameters that are optimal for
or these different types of workflows so
it's if we pick transcriptomics and then
click on next here you can see that
there are different assembly types for
transcriptomics I have a template
assembly or de novo assembly this is
going to get DeNoble assembly and
clustering and we get some in system
information then as well and so the
system information that tells me how
much I'm a trim I have on this computer
on the temporary files where all thats
gonna be processed and and how much
space is on that disk so again if you're
doing a demo what's really important is
that you've got enough free space to to
handle all the temporary files if that
says a hundred megabytes it's probably
not going to work for you you know it
needs to be you know a sizable amount of
free space in relation to how big your
data set is then we just input the
sequence files so you can load some fast
Q files here on there can be one or
multiple sets and they're typically
paired and alumina the pulldown up at
the top allows me to select a particular
read technology and there are enough
differences in the read technologies in
terms of how much data the air profile
the length of reads that different
parameters are optimal for ion torrent
savers is alumina and so our software is
flexible enough then to accommodate the
different types of input data that you
might have and and so it's important to
make that specification there are some
parameters to that can be adjusted with
this de novo algorithm it's really a
limited set of parameters we have other
workflows that have quite a few more
knobs and dials that you can adjust to
to improve the assembly in this case is
really a murse eyes and a limit on the
number of reads and if you don't know
what any of those things mean there's a
help then you down to about help button
down at the bottom and the help then is
contextual so if I click help on this
page it'll tell me what these different
things are you can also see in the side
panel get kind of a history I can click
on the side panel to a move back and
forth through the wizard something
that's newer and
some of the newer versions of seeking an
engine and so really limited parameters
and then I get his name what my outputs
going to be this is tilapia and where
it's going to go and my assembly output
will be a dot transcriptome folder it's
really a whole collection of assembled
mrnas and little editable project files
and then a table allows me to navigate
we put those on a folder together as
well as the FASTA files of all the
transcripts that have been assembled and
so at this point it's ready ready to
assemble and you just click Next and the
assembly runs and depending on how much
data you have it's going to take
anywhere from probably you know six
hours to a couple of days if it's a
really large data set now the results
from this particular data set there's
about 60 million input reads and most of
them assemble a lot of times with the
Nobel transcriptomes you don't get
eighty or ninety percent of the data
assembling a lot of transcriptome
datasets have a genomic contamination or
fragmentation and you know aren't quite
as clean and you may get you know
sometimes as well as fifty to sixty
percent of the data but on a real clean
data set you'll get you know upwards of
eighty to ninety percent this this one
took a little longer at 13 hours a lot
of times it is if the size will go you
know eight hours or so and we get 27,000
transcripts that are annotated and so
what that means is those are transcripts
that when the algorithm goes through the
assembled transcripts and compares them
to a database sequence that it can
identify them and so the database
sequence then is the mRNA it'll
automatically linked up of the mRNA
database at NCBI and scan the assembled
transcripts against all the different
annotated transcripts and find the
strongest hits and say it looks like
this transcript belongs to this this
gene and it came from this organism so
with the tilapia most of the assembled
transcripts were identified some of them
are considered novel they really didn't
hit anything strongly
so we had this kind of collection of
unannotated transcripts as well it so
it's a real streamlined kind of workflow
in the output then is a interactive
report and this report then is about
gravity for kind of a highlighter here
you can see that there's identified
transcripts tab and a novel transcript
tab on this table and there's a number
of different columns and so there's a
gene name there's an organism name an
accession number a description is
retrieved and then there's some metrics
on how well my DeNoble transcript
matched the database mRNA sequence so I
get the length of the transcript you
know the match here and I like looking
at the mash and when I see matches that
are you know over ninety-nine percent
I'm pretty confident that my assembled
you know my assemble transcript is
matching or I have most of it's nearly
if not complete it's really close to
being a full-length transcript so the
more that I get that our above ninety
percent I'm confident that I really get
you know a nice transcriptome assembly
and there's some other metrics like like
identity and [ __ ] score that are more
statistical but I'd like to just look at
you know how well these transcripts
match the database and so this is
tremendously useful then I can do a
number of things with this table it's
interactive I can double click on any
one of these rows and go to the actual
assembled cluster of reads for that
transcript and so if you want to go in
and edit you can go into the software
then edit a particular transcript and if
to context hit the same mRNA sequence
for instance it's in some cases with if
you have thinner coverage on a
transcript you may find that it's able
you're able to denote will assemble the
front part of a transcript in the back
part but they don't connect in the
middle to you to pieces and those are
extremely troublesome when you're trying
to annotate a transcriptome because
they're in there twice and there could
be thousands of those in some data sets
and so it's extremely laborious
go through and figure out where all the
duplicates are and so what we do here is
we group them and you can see this kind
of a crazy color scheme and the grouping
is saying that these you know these hit
the same in this case the same gene
right they had the same gene name so
we're going to group them together and
and we're going to treat them that way
so if I choose my next step then which
may be RNA seek our algorithms will say
oh those are actually the same even
though they're in two or three pieces
they're really the same gene so let's
calculate an expression signal and
compute them together rather than force
the customer go through thousands of
transcripts and piece them together
manually which could you know literally
be days or weeks of manual curation
saves a huge amount of an effort you can
still get the expression values that you
need and use these transcripts even
though they're not all put together some
of them might not be put together you
can still use them for your RNA seek
analysis so we can skip right to the
next step which can be RNA seek and I'll
just show you the interface then which
is look very similar but the RNA seek
then I can select a transcript of RNA
seek same kind of workflow and you can
see the interface will look a little bit
different downstream a little bit but i
can pick template at assembly now
instead of the novo i'm going to be
aligning now to that set of reference
transcripts that it created and so now
it asks for the input of the template
files with the de novo assembly of
course but we're not-- there were no
templates and in this case we're loading
the output from our de novo assembly so
there's a couple of ways I can do this I
can you can see the file path where
there is my dot transcriptome package
that was the output and the algorithm
will automatically look inside that
output and identify and find the files
that contain the identified not
annotated transcripts and the novel
transcript so we'll just kind of do that
for you or I think this ad excuse me
individual fasta files from that output
so a couple different ways I can set
this up and but i'm going to use those
now as a template and i'm going to line
a dish
the data for my RNA see and so in this
case it's a multiple sample RNA seek so
I've loaded six data files and there's
some controls at the top so you can see
where it says multiple sample data when
I select that I'm then asked to name the
different groups and I'm going to run
these as separate assemblies and I may
or may not have replicates for the
assembly and so if you've got you may
have technical replicates that you want
to run or you know any kind of
replication to normalize the signal
that's all possible this particular data
set I do not have replicates I have a
experiment that I've labeled I liver and
muscle so again this is three different
tissue types from the tilapia and we're
going to align these these are paired
alumina files so it's one set of pairs
per sample and we're going to line that
to the 27,000 plus some novel
transcripts reference sequences all at
one time and so once that assembly is
done I can open this up in our array
star software and what we're looking at
now is a gene table and the gene table
has multiple annotation fields now it's
pulling that annotation information in
from our annotations that we got from
our noble transcripts and so this is
really the exciting part now is actually
making use of all those transcripts and
making use of those annotations so
things like gene name of the description
of the gene the organism name on the
header here this all comes from
automatically from our de novo
transcriptome workflow and then way over
here on the side we can see some of the
RP km values so for the three different
sets we have our PM values of the I the
liver the muscle and erased our then has
a whole series of tools then that I can
used to compare these different sets and
that's really you know more of an
interactive software thing so look at
the we do live webinars or one-on-one
webinars with customers we can show you
that interactivity with the software but
once I have these annotations I can also
use them to filter and say only show me
from this orca type of organism or this
kind of a gene show me you know jeans
with interesting expression patterns and
so erased our then give us all different
views so i'm just showing here is a full
set of tools for comparing different
sets we have scatter plots and heat maps
and there's quick filters and statistics
that we can apply you can see that
there's clustering and different tables
for genes that we can make these
comparisons so it's a really an
excellent set of tools for making gene
expression comparisons so with that I'd
like to just summarize a few things and
i said i would get back to licensing
options again if you already have access
to the software you know this is there
some new information for you but if you
if you don't have access there's
different types of licenses we have
desktop and network and institute wide
we have cloud workstations feel free to
contact me if any questions that you
have about either the function of
software or the the way that you can
access it again technical support is
available central time 7 am-6 p.m. we
have many different training resources
on our website webinars videos tutorials
and manuals and of course you can always
reach out to me I can help you out with
any any questions that you have and with
that I'll look and seem kind of
questions we have and try to answer them
on the fly so I have one question can I
use different annotation databases yes
there's there's flexibility in the
database and that's something it's a
little bit technical depending on the
database that you have but yeah you can
use different types of annotation
databases for the workflow and I have
another questions or a limit to the
total number of sequences that can be
done
assembled it's really only a limit to
your computer resources so most
computers that have a couple terabytes
of scratch disk space and say 32 gigs of
ram we've tests it up to about 500
million reads but there's no reason that
we can't do a billion reads or or even
more than that if you have the time and
patience to you know wait a few more
days for the assembly complete so again
with that I'd like to thank everybody
and hope to see you next time Thank you
Thank what happened sorry about that
little technical issue sorry about that
thank you Matt for bringing that
important information to us I also want
to thank your company DNA stars for
making today's webcast possible
attendees today will receive an email
when this webcast is available for
on-demand replay we would invite you to
share that email with any colleagues so
we're not able to log on to the live
broadcast today thank you again for
joining us see you again next time